я буду на маленьку істоту так
називаєте зате харківського
євромайдану
активіст Володин від шестерень дружини
веретено we влади
на виборах до парламенту на голову руку
його майдані у ціни мало жодного шансу
районі який стане 10 рук у власова
у запарку екс-президентом тягача віктора
януковича
тепер активістами чоловіка вигляд самого
йти видно знаємо законом про вибори
у хваленому вже нинішньому владимир якщо на
парламентських випали на парламентських
виборах я йшов у гавана висунув майдан
собою люди щось у сьогоднішньому back to me та
політичні партії я на бачу дружини та
політичні сили та й [ __ ] їх би
праведно тася будь-яку яму при монсі ось
партії нової парламентської коаліції у
харку і доки додовили солодкі без шістьох
містер у їхніх пологах депутати цих спрощує
партер юним частина її людей часті на її
людей уже вийшли до партії порошенка блок
Петра Порошенка часті на мімікро увалів
партію відродження обидва називається б
вказівним блоком називає себе
опозиційний блок опозиційний блок
catrice дебіл чого складається з
звичною ким кілочки кута та й також
позначиться на поселення мови mignews дасин
ізар is true wow партію для uc шість
міс цілих виборах у харкові
зараз юристи судити з міністерством їх
чон і областям і днями реєстра тиною
буду блок не братом і участі у вибору
чесно-чесно політична конкуренція
влада боїться опоненті влада боїться
конструктивної опозиції та робот навчальної
законний спосіб щоб треба порожні то
нашу парламенті q силу до вибору
регіоні місті багряний ресурсів то лади
містері вибору у харкові обіцяють стати
на ісккон надалі видав таборі рукою
мабуть таким допомогти йому і такі дні
форми petcube узо формулу гро сьогодні на
голос голос в обмін на бачу
волосся в обмін на поки це кліки і так і
еньші
на пакетик ліків і так далі прямого
людей 2 влади віднести що за 40
кілометр лідку дону в Росію задоволений і
достатньо скасування євромайданів адже
владимир чи частини там активісти
викидати злобну площу харкова та
оксані кажуть до повної пари
завантаження глади